can this morning's I on earth one of the
world's most iconic cities is partly
underwater Venice Italy is suffering its
worst flooding in more than 50 years at
least two people have died and the
damage is estimated in the hundreds of
millions of dollars here's what the
city's most famous st. Mark's Square
normally looks like here's how it looks
swamped by floodwaters Holly Williams is
on Venice's Grand Canal with the reasons
behind the flooding
good morning they call this acqua alta
here in italy or high water and it often
happens in winter but this year it's
much worse than usual the regional
governor is calling this a quote
apocalyptic disaster and Italy is
expected to declare a state of emergency
later on today when your city is built
on a lagoon water is a fact of life
Venice floods dozens of times every year
but the Venetians say this isn't normal
national told us her family's five
stores were all flooded Lycia it's too
much in a city that earns a living from
it's gorgeous views and the tens of
millions of tourists who come to see
them every year this inundation is a
disaster soon mark Square was already a
tourist attraction when it was captured
by the painter Canaletto 300 years ago
now it submerged in water so deep this
man turned the famous Piazza into a
private swimming pool this was a perfect
storm very high winds a flood and a city
that's mostly 4 to 5 feet above sea
level but experts say what's making
things worse here in Venice is climate
change and rising sea levels st. Mark's
Basilica its structure dating back
around a thousand years has flooded just
six times in its history but twice in
the last two years this flood has caused
hundreds of millions of dollars of
damage to a jewel of a city so precious
it's a World Heritage Site
has been building flood barriers since
2003 at a cost of billions of dollars
but the project is ten years behind
schedule and has been plagued by
allegations of corruption Tony
everyone's got such beautiful boats
there and then in Boots and the church
almost looks like fun but that is
trouble yes real trouble and she said it
is a jewel of the city it's one of my
favorite places in the world if this is
heartbreaking
back tacular Polly thank you very much